[Music]
boy that's a difficult question how do i
define success it's a tough one I don't
have any specifics for that if I leave
something that is some sort of legacy
for my children and grandchildren and
that legacy is kind of undefined right
it could be inheritance
it could be something cultural something
business I really don't know and it's
kind of still up in the air at this
point you know that's good we're driving
I've been in my 40s and I still don't
know I would just say generally you're
in a place where you're happy and I
guess that's really it
what in life makes me happy that's gonna
vary by person
I don't know I don't have a good answer
for that a success to me means reaching
your goal being happy about your goal
and being confident with that my
ultimate goal I have brain cancer now so
the beat brain cancer would be my
ultimate goal and then successful I
don't really care what I what I do in
life but I want to experience a lot job
wise doesn't really matter any anything
that can get me by and afford me the
things that I like and I want to do that
that's success to me probably a lot to
do with happiness in relationships
because the people around you tend to be
the people that make you happy so I
don't really want to get very specific
but I think in the general sensitive
that would be
self-fulfillment through relationships
yeah growing up since I'm like part
Asian success was us growing up Fitness
you know getting a pluses you didn't get
a a-plus it was a shame and I feel like
I did succeed for my grandparents
because I graduated top of my class so I
feel like I have a success and I feel
like my definition of you know the word
success has been completed just because
of what I did for my family you know
what's your ultimate goal for the future
mmm a lot of my friends here are from
different countries I hope to achieve
visiting them in every one of their
countries and there was over 10 so
getting that done this year
tell all of you guys not here yep Lima
in the USA hostel
I moved down here from Seattle to work
here a little over three years ago and
so far I've done some pretty incredible
things here in the park and San Diego I
think I'm successful finally
are you nervous I am what do you do I
paint miniatures two murals and I can
paint just about anything on just about
anything how could you find your work I
have a Facebook page
funny chance visual artists on Facebook
and also an Instagram i would say
happiness is success for me that's
owning my own barbershop and
yeah that's about it owning uh only a
really small barber shop and being happy
with it Oh success means that there is
no wreckage left in your weight but you
can sleep easy
after you finish it and you're so happy
it's done that's what success is so
success for me means that if I can look
back at the day and I have brought
someone joy then I have been successful
I'd be here with my dream job and my
family's healthy and stuff what's your
dream job to be a model feeling
accomplished at the end of the day I
don't really have a limit for success I
don't think that it you ever get to one
place where you're ever kind of done
entirely accomplished in life success is
just being able to do whatever you want
to do with whoever you want to do it
with whenever you want to do it and
enjoying what you do enjoying your work
enjoying life yeah yeah I do the balance
of feeling like I am accomplishing
something with my business and my
professional side but also that I'm you
have a happy family and my kids are
happy good relationship with your
friends and family and peace I think
basically just achieving whatever goals
you have so it's personal so it's not
something that somebody can measure for
you so they can be objective and
subjective just winning at life biggest
goal its Agora I got an enjoy him
forever it's it being able to have
enough money to support myself and
travel wherever I want to it means being
able to make enough money and be happy
with the choices that I make in life
changing the cannabis industry in the
country for me and how do you plan on
doing that oh I have no idea definitely
still working on it though it's just
trying to be the person I want to be
every single day and hopefully that
turns into my long-term career goals
whatever that that is
having a fulfilling job that you enjoy
having a family that is healthy that
you're close to and getting to do the
things you love most in life not being
Donald Trump doing something you truly
love and making it successful I'm a
professional dog trainer so one thing I
do is I help a lot of people who have
disabilities who aren't able to go out
and live their everyday life like me so
I help them and I would love to just be
able to bring awareness to how important
that is for people there's a lot of
people who are stuck doing nothing and I
want them to do something I think
success has many definitions but one
definition that stands out would be the
ability to express myself and connect
with the people around me that would
make me feel successful so happiness
love and being loved being in love and
that's what are you successful I am
I just wanted to ask you guys real quick
to turn on the notifications button on
my channel right next to the subscribe
button is this little bell if you click
that you'll get notified every time a
company video that way you're not
missing out
[Music]